yep
okay link before I go in there oh all
right
balls to the wall hey I'm here with you
right oh boy oh yeah you hey I said
don't
boom you know I know
ah ah hey moving just get water they're
gonna go oh hi hi how do you get to oh I
see I don't like this game I know how to
beat it what's this what's this ha ha
he's everywhere
what are these some SCP for 20 minute
wait a minute
ha ha ha ha man mmm good a [ __ ] man ha
ha don't open not you dick you dick you
dick you dick you dick damn door door
get the door
I came in oh yeah I made it through one
room surprise [ __ ]
this has been the SCP reaction
compilation thanks for watching if you
like what you saw and you want to see
more why not subscribe to my channel and
if you want to help the channel grow
please leave a like add it to your
favorites or share it with your friends
on Facebook and Twitter thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye